hey this is david philly here at
comic-con 2019 we're phil was lucky
enough to play astral chain the latest
game from platinum games with supervisor
Hideki Kamiya who of course is famous
for creating Devil May Cry entire genre
games Bayonetta and the major game
designer the lead game designer behind
it was the lead game designer behind it
near automatic or automata I was
confused with the way you pronounce it
but Phil that leads me to my first
question which is if you had to compare
the two is astral chain work in the
nearer or to Bayonetta I would say it's
more Bayonetta it's more of a
hack-and-slash style of the game it's
yeah it feels a lot more double may cry
but you know with its new interesting
take on the idea right because you have
that new lesions that you get to use and
how has that really change the way that
the gameplay works now that you have an
extra essentially allied that you can
sort of control to sort of not control
yeah it's kind of like having two
characters to control but in a an easier
to deal with way than that sounds okay
yeah yeah exactly right so what you
you're just a regular character running
around you've got like a baton that can
turn into a gun or to a big sword and
there's only one attack button for that
thing but you just hack away at it and
roll off combos but then on the left
trigger you can pull out your Legion and
he is like a dog with swords on a leash
attached to your hand and and you just
can you know send him into battle with
one button you're just kind of like yeah
out there kill that and he'll do that
you can direct him by holding the
trigger and like send them out to
specific places or to trigger different
puzzle elements or whatever in the game
so you have a degree of control it feels
like you're fighting and you're
controlling him but you can just let him
do his thing - so how much that the game
did you actually get to play I played a
good 20 minutes I played basically a
full like side mission it felt like okay
and completed a boss fight and a sub
boss fight for another section okay so
did you actually play any of the
police-station part of the game because
there that element or do any
investigation because there's also
investigating to this game as well
you're like a space anime cop
investigating the astral
there's weird I don't know what's going
on the story but it seems yeah but yeah
I did go out in like we were out in the
city I wasn't in the police station but
I was out in the city you could talk to
people and we headed out to a crime
scene where like someone had gone
missing there was all kinds of astral
plane evidence yeah and I was like
checking it out a couple places I had to
send my Legion to like check the
evidence because he could do interesting
astral plane stuff because that's where
he's from yeah and then we determined
that someone had been grabbed by a
chimera which is an astral plane monster
that are like bleeding into our world
and then we tracked it with my Legion
like a like a bloodhound okay basically
all the way through the city till we
found a gate to the astral plane and
then we went and like took the fight to
him that was the investigation aspect of
it actually fun to do I know you had a
pretty limited window to do it order to
feel very like okay this is really
obvious you do a you go to be go to see
you talk to d-iii
it's hard for me to really give it too
much of a judgement because it was
really a very small slice of an
investigation for me like it we walked
into the crime scene there are three
interactive pieces of evidence on the
ground like you get some information
about them yeah and then we were off and
running
tracking the scent right but I did see a
little glimpse of how that'll be a
larger system it feels like these
investigations are going to kind of pile
up to give you more information about
what's going on maybe in larger story
missions or other side quests you've got
like a police notebook and as you're
gaining information or talking to people
you're putting down like key words in
your book right so you've got like
information one of them was a red ghost
was a phrase someone had used yeah in
another case or in another part of the
story that I didn't get to play but that
was directly related to the guy I was
searching for so I was like compiling
information about him from other times
other places yeah and so yeah you're
able to go back into that notebook and
like look at the details and figure out
you know what the context of that stuff
was and you're I think kind of putting
all that together to maybe solve a
larger case or the you know the larger
case of the story with all the astral
plane stuff going on yeah I'm not sure
exactly but it seemed like there was
more to it than just you know click on
that spot on the ground okay let's get
in here did you do any actual policing
I know that's actually not women - is
that you can police normal people as
well I didn't actually I did help a few
people along the way like a few people
were sick with astral plane goo I don't
know exactly they were in a bad way and
I was able to use my legion to like heal
them and that gives you a little extra
like points or experience points or
something with a little bit of
interaction within the city and you can
kind of clean the place up yeah that way
but no we were kind of off and running
on that that one mission to fight that
guy and save the person he took to the
astral plane right and I think I'm sure
the element that most people are excited
about is the gameplay itself because
that's what these action games are known
for and we were talking about the
lesions but how smooth did it feel did
it make you feel cool because I was
definitely Devil May Cry the whole idea
is I want you to feel cool it was great
yes super good yeah so like you're kind
of executing these combos and stuff all
the time almost faster than you realize
you're doing it because that comes like
second nature so you're like smashing
away at a guy with your baton which you
know we've got a fast strike baton the
bigger like sword Buster Sword looking
one or gun and like as you're racking up
hits you'll get a like a little prompt
we're like a glowing circle around you
and that's like hey throw your legion in
there and you hit the legion button he
jumps out he wails on him that adds to
your combo then you can follow up with a
strike hit the legion again hate the guy
again then do a like a finisher where
the Legion rips whatever the core of the
Chimera is out yeah like heals you and
heals him so it's a it's very you know
it it all kind of piles on together
really fast
where you're like suddenly you're just
wailing on people and you're bouncing
from one guy to the next and your
legions off killing people for it on
this side and and they're like okay come
over here and you've kind of he's like
flinging you into a fight and it does
cool things so you use him for like
platforming to let me send him out and
then he'll whip you back with the with
the chain to let get you over gaps and
stuff how much platform is in the game I
know like a ton but I definitely like as
we were navigating the astral plane we
had a few things when you jump over gaps
and like yeah when you're fighting
bosses or sub-bosses you have to do a
little bit more than just combo up do
you platform on them possibly or how do
you actually fight them and tackle it
definitely feels like there's going to
be probably making use of different
aspects of the Legion stuff like that
one thing that you could do that was
real
cool is so you've got the légion
tethered to you on this lake
spectral chain right that's the I'll
call it in astral exactly but it's a
physical court right so like you can
send your legion around a dude
yeah and wrap him up with the chain
right and then this stunned and then you
just wail on them and you're doing
combos off that and like gives you even
on bosses like it is you a second or
like breed or get off the fight or just
you know whale way yeah do some serious
damage so you got stuff like that
you've got other enemies who are like
tethering with different enemies and
like giving them invulnerability right
and so then you have to do a thing where
you are you're getting your legion to
like do a sword move but you have to
line it up with the spectral cord that's
between these two enemies so right cut
it to stop their connections so you feel
like to stop and like line that up yeah
there's like there's a lot of different
things it's not just like strategy yeah
exactly yeah just whaling on the yard
button the whole time you've got to
think about what you're doing yeah what
was the one thing that you'd say really
stood out to you while playing is I just
really liked that the way you get going
with combos yeah and like just whaling
on guys and with the Legion and you know
bouncing him off calling him back in
right doing cool things with him pulling
it doing the like the chain thing
there's a lot of thinking going on about
what that guy is off doing and what you
want him to do and but not so much that
you're like babysitting him he's off
killing stuff and yes he's a really good
partner basically like I really liked
having that guy attached to me and the
cool things that we could do together
but I didn't have to like escort him you
know yeah would you say that the lesion
is a big enough deviation from saint
bayonetta or Devil May Cry to make it
worth picking up astral Chan if you're a
fan of these types of games I think so
yeah and I'm interested in in the other
stuff too like the investigations and
the story components all seem really
well fleshed out too so it's not just
like you know a fighting game there's a
lot more going on there that I'm really
interested in checking it out well I am
super excited I'm a huge fan of it
Platinum Games in general Bayonetta is
my jam maker I was great and I also love
near so when can people get their hands
on astral chain it is on Nintendo switch
exclusively next
month August 30th well figured up August
30th and yeah thanks so much Phil I'm
jealous they get the plates